millions of people around the country
are feeling worse off elliot bought this
house in kettering two years ago but
having just remortgaged he's anxious
about how much more he's now paying
we were currently paying 580 pounds a
month and it's gone up to over 800
pounds
and can you afford that
i mean
it's going to be tight it's going to be
a lot tighter than it was before and
with the rising costs of fuel food the
economy in general it is going to be a
struggle
two-thirds of the british public say
they're concerned about rising interest
rates according to a new poll but it's
younger people feeling most financial
stress
essentially any borrower will feel worse
off if they have a loan or a mortgage
that's not on a fixed term rate but
renters may be impacted too if their
landlords pass the cost of their higher
mortgages onto them making it even
tougher for people struggling to get on
the property ladder with their rent
eating into their savings
hafsa has moved back in with her parents
along with her husband and baby while
they try to save for a house deposit
i'm 36 and i thought by this age i would
have had my own property and i've been a
pharmacist since 2013. so i definitely
thought by now i would have my own
property i'm in a profession which pays
pretty well um and so it would be quite
straightforward and i'm quite i guess
i'm not upset i think i'm just a bit
demotivated actually i've been i've
worked really hard i've studied really
hard and i'm still not able to buy a
property
some will remember the late 1970s when
interest rates hit 17
in a bid to fight sky-high inflation
this led to eye-watering remortgage
payments and a paralyzed housing market
our mortgage rates heading back towards
double digits
i think people that can remember those
times um you know are very worried now
although they're probably retired now
and they're still worried cost of living
going up
but people have never experienced it
it's like the unknown you know what is
going to happen where is interest rates
going to finish
um but we hope that um you know
the government you know we'll sort it
there will be things that they can do
the cost of living is putting pressure
on households around the country but
financial concerns appear most acute
among younger generations sally lockwood
sky news